Korean singles commonly begin dating in college.
They go on mee-ting, group blind dates.
Mee-ting, mee-ting.
Mee-ting usually involves a lot of alcohol, drinking games, and laughter.
These group blind dates have an equal number of females and males.
Participants privately discuss who they're most interested in.
And hopefully pair up with their preferred choice.
Even if you don't find romance,...
...mee-ting is a wonderful opportunity to network...
...and to make some unforgettable memories.
On the other hand, so-gae-ting are one-on-one blind dates.
A mutual friend or acquaintance will play matchmaker,...
...and set you up with someone they believe is fitting to you.
They may know the individual personally,...
...or know them through a series of mutual friends.
By the way, it's not "so getting", it's so-gae-ting.
So-gae-ting, so-gae-ting.
Seon is another type of blind date.
But this one's arranged by parents.
Because the potential in-laws are prescreened,...
...parents feel more comfortable with this option.
Family approval in marriage or dating can make or break a couple.
In ideal cases, individuals find their husband or wife after several seon blind dates.
Needless to say, arranged dates are widely accepted in Korea.